la santé c'est comme un jardin ça se
cultive sur son terrain de 3 hectares
malik recense une centaine d'espèces
végétales
parmi elles le manioc son produit phare
il disparaît de plus en plus des terres
martiniquaise on constate une
importation du manioc aujourd'hui en
martinique alors qu'on pourrait
développer cette culture qui aujourd'hui
extraordinaire ce produit ils utilisent
pour confectionner des mais ces 30 kg de
racine serviront à réaliser une pizza à
base de manioc
ici on l'appelle lapize manioc j'aime
bien la transformation de la plante
commence dans ce laboratoire première
étape passée le manioc à la
centrifugeuse ce qu'on obtient ici après
avoir passé le manioc
c'est ce qu'on obtient on va maintenant
le mettre à sécher
donc nous on le fait de façon ancestrale
et on n'a pas de presse et caetera
donc on les met dans des sacs et puis on
les met à sécher on me dit pierre dessus
etc
jusqu'à ce que ça coule et que tout le
liquide qui est dedans puis ce parti
mais alors que le liquide est parti à ce
moment là on le récupère et on le fait
passer nous n'en saurons pas plus sur la
confection de la pâte
le chef tient à garder le secret ils
préfèrent nous montrer un des
ingrédients utiles à la garniture de la
piste manioc pour lui de la terre à
l'assiette on ne jette rien on utilise
tout on transforme tout sur une arme
qu'on utilise beaucoup et qu'on
transforme
elle y fut notamment donc on les
déshydrate pour faire de la poudre de
moringa autrement les fleurs qui sont
des fleurs comestibles donc dans notre
alimentation dans nos pires direction la
cuisine changement de casquette pour la
confection de lapize manioc
tout ça peu de basilic frais il ya un
adage qui dit que si manger biya qui bon
bacon nous est en effet tout ce qui
pousse autour de nous qui est bon pour
nous et en plus de ça nous tenons
absolument à remplir pleinement notre
fonction d'agriculteurs qui de nourrir
sainement le peuple